Good to go.
Okay. All right.
Well, my name is Dan Leaphart,
and I'll be given my testimony here this evening.
Um, unlike most of the people at our church, uh, me,
my wife, we're not from around here, so I grew up in York,
Pennsylvania, and, uh, I'm an only child,
and my mom and dad were, were both Christians,
and brought me up in a good Christian home.
Uh, my earliest memory that I can remember
is my dad sitting on my bed with me.
I was about four years old, and he told me about Jesus,
and I remember asking him into my heart that night, uh,
to save me for my sins.
Uh, so my earliest childhood memory,
I don't have any memories really
before, uh, accepting Christ into my life.
Um, I grew up in a church environment my whole life.
We, uh, were not traditionally part of Baptist churches.
Uh, we've always kind of gone
to non-denominational or Bible churches.
Um, and all through my childhood years, I was,
I would say, a good Christian kid.
I love the Lord, love reading his word, um,
through elementary school.
And, uh, talking about Jesus to my friends.
And I guess when I entered into
that middle school time period is when, um, as
with everything else, uh,
people go through a lot of changes.
And I would say at that point in time, uh, I started
to really care more about the world
and what others thought of me, and
therefore, uh, less of what God thought of me.
Uh, still went to church, um, still prayed,
and I would say that continued up
until going off to college.
Uh, so I went off to a four year school undergrad.
My, my degree is in geology, uh,
to a school in Lancaster, Pennsylvania.
It's only about 45 minutes away.
And I remember when my parents dropped me off,
uh, in my dorm, um,
they were gonna say goodbye, go back home.
I was gonna start my life there as a college student.
My dad handed me this Bible.
It's an Oswald Chambers Daily Devotional Bible.
And looking back on that time, I, I took it
because he was my dad.
Uh, but looking back on that time, I remember being
embarrassed that here I am in a college, um,
the last thing I really wanted was a Bible.
Um, so what did I do?
I took it back to my dorm room
and I put it into the bottom cupboard of my,
or the bottom drawer in my room.
And there it would stay for about the next
Four years. So
I'm gonna fast forward a little bit of time
my senior year getting ready to graduate.
And I remember not having a plan for my life.
Um, I remember, um,
really not knowing
and not being sure what a geology degree is gonna do.
I tried getting jobs. It wasn't, wasn't really working out.
But I did remember one thing I remembered, I had this Bible,
and I remember praying, God,
I know I'm not on a good path here.
What, what is it that I'm supposed to do?
What, what should I actually even read?
And the thing about this 365 daily devotional Bible
is it has daily readings,
and it has old New Testament, psalms,
and proverbs for each day.
And I remember flipping it open
to whatever day that happened to be.
Um, doesn't really matter,
but I remember the proverbs were the shortest part of
that daily scripture reading.
And so I remember reading it, and what did I read?
I read something about the Sluggard.
Um, and I realized
after reading that, that I was that sluggard.
I was like, God, that didn't feel very good,
but I knew I needed it.
So I went the next day, I read the next Proverbs,
I went the next day, read the next Proverbs,
and God was speaking to me
through the proverbs.
And I remember that that was the starting point of
realizing that God had to be more important in my life, um,
all through my senior year and then into summer.
And then I needed an extra semester in the fall.
This was back in 1997 through the summer.
I remember going home and I was at my parents' church,
and I got involved and I was on the worship team, uh,
played the guitar for the worship team.
And in the fall, uh,
we had something called a Country jamboree
where I played the guitar dressed up like cowboy.
And that was the first time that I met Danielle,
who's my, my wife.
And, uh, we got to, to talking.
And, uh, it was January
of 1998 when I got up the nerve
to ask her out for the first time.
We had our first date. And things were going
well until about February when, uh,
I was out late at night in college and,
and, uh, coming back to my apartment
and got into a, a car wreck.
Um, fortunately nobody was hurt.
It was not a major collision. Um, took everybody home.
And, and I remember all that night just
Crying out to the Lord, God,
I am not on a good path here.
What is it that you want me to do?
I have no idea what I'm gonna do, but I know I need you
and I need you to change this course in my life.
And we'll call that first part of my life. Act one.
From that night on, we'll call it Act two.
And I remember things were different after that night.
Danielle and I were still dating.
Uh, by April of that year, we actually got engaged.
So after dating her for three months,
and, uh, we started reading the Bible together,
and we read Genesis one together the next
day, Genesis two together.
And I was like, this isn't fast enough for me.
Uh, God is actually wanting me
to go a little bit, a little bit quicker right now.
So I, I kept reading at my own pace.
Um, by August of that year, uh, we got married.
And what I didn't say between our engagement in April
and our marriage or our wedding in August, uh,
we had an important decision.
I was gonna go on to graduate school for geology,
and I had two options.
I could go to the University of Maryland
or New Mexico Tech now growing up in Pennsylvania,
which makes the most sense.
So we visited both schools, gave 'em an equal shot.
Uh, Maryland offered me a good teaching assistantship,
good, good pay.
And New Mexico did not offer me anything.
So visiting Maryland, I remember the dean
of the geology department asking me
what New Mexico was gonna offer us.
And I said, well, they weren't offering me anything.
And he laughed at me as to why I would even consider them.
And I knew right then
and there that Maryland was not the school
where God wanted us to be.
So the very next day, we prayed about it,
got a phone call from New Mexico Tech.
They offered me actually a better job than
what Maryland was gonna offer us.
So we knew that was where God was leading us to go.
So from Pennsylvania, we got married in August,
came back from the honeymoon,
and we drove all the way across the country to the desert
of New Mexico for two years of graduate school.
And I remember that time getting my degree,
but also God just giving me this unquenchable
thirst for his word.
I read through the Bible for the very first time in my life
at that, at that point, um, when I was done,
I flipped it over and read it again, read it again.
And I could tell that that was just a, a just a period of,
of, of real, real growth
in my walk with Christ.
And two years into that, we got a job
and we moved to the Woodlands, Texas, outside of Houston,
uh, also going to New Mexico, exposed us
to the oil and gas industry.
And that's what I do. That's, that's what I still do today.
And that actually is what brought us here to Oklahoma.
So, uh, going from New Mexico to Houston, while in Houston
for seven years, uh, our three boys were born, all
of them born in, in Texas.
Uh, our oldest is Nathan. He's 23.
He is also now in the graduate program at ou.
He's a math mathematics major.
And Seth, our middle child, uh, he just recently got married
to his wife, Kelly, uh,
who we love our first daughter-in-Law.
And he is now a senior at OSU in, uh, strategic, um,
uh, strategic communications.
And Cooper, our youngest is 18,
and he's all the way up in Marquette
University, in Milwaukee.
Uh, he's in the Army, ROTC program,
and he just contracted with the Army.
Uh, so we're, uh, super proud of him,
uh, also.
And so also in that year, those years in Texas, uh,
we went to a Bible church,
and the, the pastor there was a
PhD Greek scholar.
And I remember being so stimulated by that,
that you could have such a, an academic
and such an intellectual approach to God's word,
that there was literally no depth limit to
what you could do, uh, in your, in your study of the Bible.
So during those years, I started to pick up a little Greek
on my own, uh, to go into those deeper dives, into,
into the God's Word.
Um, in 2007, we moved to West Virginia,
had an op opportunity to go there with an oil company.
And, uh, that lasted about two years.
We were happy to be with family or closer to family, uh,
but God brought that to an end in 2009.
And the only job that I had was here in Oklahoma City,
tried to get other jobs.
We did not want to move to Oklahoma City.
Um, but looking back on that now, we know
that was God's plan for us,
and we've grown to love Oklahoma City
shortly after moving here.
We, uh, came, started attending to, uh, uh, Henderson Hills
shortly after attending Henderson Hills.
Uh, we started out in the, uh, Conrad Red Wine flock.
It's back in 2009.
Uh, and after a little bit of time, uh, started
to join the teaching team with Jason Redwine
and, and Eric Harp.
And, um, that was really the start
of me getting into teaching here at the church.
Um, and since then, we've, we've effectively been a part of
that heritage of community group ever since.
Um, Eric Harp and Courtney and Danielle
and myself, we, we spun off,
started a community group back in 2013,
and we are still a part of that community group today.
Eric and Courtney have, have, uh,
left the leadership of that group.
And, and now we're co-leading with, uh, Troy
and Sherry Talley.
Um, just teaching
through the Bible on Sunday morning, second Service.
Um, while here at Henderson Hills,
I've gotten the privilege to lead, you know, several
men's Bible studies, uh, in addition
to teaching in the community group, uh, taught a couple
of HTI classes and then one of my favorites.
Got to teach a short course on Wednesday nights on
how we got the Bible and the history of the revelation
and preservation of God's word.
Uh, one of my, my passion subjects.
Um, but we're at a stage of life right now
where our youngest child is,
has moved off into his college in the beginning of his,
his life, independent.
And we were praying about
how God could use us in this next phase.
And the timing was perfect, uh, to be able to,
to have these conversations about, well,
have we considered eldership here at Henderson Hills?
Um, and we've been praying about
this and praying about this.
And over the last two years, uh, we're, we're convinced now
that God is wanting to use us in this way
to serve this body.
Uh, so I'm excited about it.
Uh, I love this last two years of the,
of the mentoring process, going
through it with Chris and Trevor.
Uh, it's been a joy
and now ready to, to kick off, uh,
the full-time, full-time work.
Um, so, um, we love this church
and we love the Lord and anything we can do to serve,
and I'm just grateful that he's wanting us
to serve in this way.